happy July 4th homies this is coming out
on July 4th baby get the hotdogs get the
hamburgers eat like a homie yesterday my
rankings came out for my quarterback
rankings of best grill master of all the
quarterbacks but I'm recording this on
Monday because I want to go out and
celebrate July 4th
so we'll recap this next week I just
want to say we're halfway through the
year and I appreciate the homies so
freaking much and when we started the
new show and really focused on the 33% I
asked who were the guests that you guys
wanted the most and one of the groups
that came up the most was the fantasy
footballers and I'm gonna tell you that
I legitimately had never listened to a
fantasy footballers show before they are
the number one fantasy football podcast
in the world when you look up fantasy
football in iTunes their logo pops up
first and so any time I'm gonna
interview somebody I want to do a deep
dive so I'm not coming in here going who
are you guys I think you guys see I want
to be well researched and the more and
more that I looked up are the fantasy
footballers the more I realized that the
33% aligns with them and their audience
that they call the Foot Clan these are
three dudes that were working together
at a video game production company which
was my dream job when I was in second
grade
because I wanted to make crash bandicoot
and the company started to fold two of
them went you know what I'm gonna get my
real estate license and then the other
two started doing a two of the other
guys started doing a podcast and the
podcast started getting steamed and now
they're the number one fantasy football
podcast in the world they were able to
come on this show because they were
doing a stop in New York they're doing
stops in San Francisco LA Chicago all
these places and as soon as they sat
down it was like guys we're all doing
the same thing we care about our
listeners we care about the NFL we want
to talk about it differently and we just
want to make good stuff and I really
think we had a blast those guys are
awesome support
them let them know that you appreciate
them coming in here and hanging out the
33% because I have a feeling I'm gonna
do something with them again really
great guys a lot of good fun and to all
the listeners out there that are
thinking you know I really want to go on
camera I really want to do podcasts or I
really want to do something with
football and you're doing a job that
you're not sure you want to do use these
guys as inspiration too because they're
doing this journey and they're coming at
it with love and they're pouring
everything into what they're doing and
that's the reason they're successful so
we're gonna get to a quick little add a
little advertisement and then it's gonna
be a lot more fantasy footballers so to
all the homies all the 33% enjoy your
hot dog your hamburger your lobster roll
however you celebrate July 4th and let
me know if you like this interview you
guys are the Shi T I am the LEF koe man
I just spelled a curse word I will
holler at you guys but in the meantime
enjoy the fantasy football I was gonna
like start and I looked up and the eyes
are closed and he's diggin it he's the
musician I would introduce the homies
the 33% to the number one fantasy
podcast I think in the world the fantasy
universe Reaper
Andy Holloway let's top five most
accurate analysts to 2018 let me go now
I'm feeling it yeah the man that was
feeling the music the fantasy hitman
Mike Wright a true sneaker head inside
of your eardrums and a man that enjoys
churros more than any other person yes
through the world so true and a top 10
most accurate analyst in 2017-2018 give
it up for Jason more
was gonna be show up you got to show up
that's pretty bad by comparison yes well
it's it's not easy to get those rankings
no it's not how many people are
competing on the fantasy pros website I
believe it is about 150 yeah so be
topped one is pretty damn good oh now
that's what you wanted to hear you guys
are the midst of a tour right now
Chicago New York San Francisco LA and
then back to Phoenix where you guys are
from is this the second stop it is yeah
number two how we did Chicago a couple
days ago how the Foot Clan they showing
out all those shown up they're loud
they're proud it's awesome right when
the Foot Clan gets together it's it's
just a rock show they're there screaming
hooting hollering as our manager says
it's a punk a punk rock show yeah I also
noticed there's a lot of jerseys out
there oh yeah have you got what's the
best Jersey you've seen so far Toni
Kukoc we were starting the show I don't
think it made the air cause it was
before we did the actual okay we're
gonna go Andy made a joke and then front
in the front row is a man in its own
yeah we thought it was actually him yeah
for people that do not know the fantasy
footballers when you go onto your iTunes
app or any other app they're typically
the first one that pops up you guys all
work together making video games in
Arizona you guys all played in a fantasy
football league was it you to that
started the podcast to make fun of the
rest of the guys in the league yeah so
our league which by the way our league
is not a money league which is it's just
for pride just a pride league which is
pretty shocking for a lot of people
because we care that much but ever every
year we said how do we take this league
to the next level yeah yeah one year it
was we had a buddy of ours worse wear a
suit and tie and he was our Roger
Goodell for the fantasy draft we would
bring our picks up kind of an [ __ ]
yeah yeah no that was more because I
would hit my theme music
but you had walk-up music there was a
year where it was turned down for what
that was like that was the made a pic
that was it and then it got to the point
where like let's let's just do a podcast
we'll take one of our lunch hours a week
the two of us will do it we've got all
the gear anyways because I was the audio
guy for the company and then we just it
turned into us ripping on the rest of
the league for an hour and Jason you're
just sitting there like these guys are
idiots
oh no I mean they are but much more so
just it completely entertained I loved
every minute of it yeah I would
literally in that league I would be
making trades to try and get a decent
rate asaurus rex because they had a
trade asaurus rex drop and I wanted the
Train that's awesome so this video game
company begins to fold you guys I
believe it was you to then go to get
your real estate license bris yeah the
natural pivot from video games the real
estate yeah I think it's like a great
thing is like if everything goes to [ __ ]
what job are you like one house by
myself sometime it's about what we sold
yeah you actually saw we got our license
we did God you got a license but you
made a sale we sure did couple of them
so he helped a lot of family members
I've never gotten like a comment later
being like oh my god you guys
you also screwed me on Bulow pound they
see there's an angle there we probably
should have stayed in real estate as
well and we could have probably picked
up some clients uh then you this podcast
starts to grow really in that 2014-2015
is when the podcast industry really
started to boom it's kind of I felt like
that's when it started getting put in
cars and rights when people were like
making it a part of their day and we're
saying screw terrestrial radio and now I
look you guys have won multiple awards
but I think the one that stands out to
be the most three straight years of
winning the People's Choice Awards
because anyone that does a podcast knows
you can have all the advertisers in the
world you can have all these companies
that say that's my favorite podcast but
really if the people [ __ ] with you and I
don't know if you guys curse as much
right now
but if the people mess with you that's
all that matters because that's the
reason you all do it right because it's
you
industry and you need to make money at
the same time may come on listeners are
the best it's the people community it's
the community we're always shocked even
now four years in it's like these are
the best your listeners are the best
people on earth and they build this
relationship with you and then we do
these live shows and you meet somebody
for the first time but they they know
you they've known you for years about
you yeah do you guys share a lot about
like yourselves in the podcast - yeah
decent amount I mean we try to stick to
fantasy football fear of this show this
is like okay so I wasn't gonna say
anything don't worry it's not just the
sweat that was like okay so you know
what's the Schwarzenegger Total Recall
oh yeah where that's the way he knows
that it's like a so he's not in the
dream it is that's a river and then the
glasses are fogging I can't see anybody
because here's the deal I run hot - yeah
you have no idea if somebody can come in
here with a paper towel I'm being dead
serious
greatest movie of all time yeah greatest
of all time it's on my top five
definitely in the run hot you both both
love Jim Carrey you guys are yeah most
people sweat more though my movie takes
them no I don't mind it at all okay good
high praise though you know they're so
you people probably get you guys to
grotto balls you guys though people
probably go are you guys like really
friends in real life you guys met this
company do you guys know each other
before the company Jason and I we go
back to high school
Wow yeah so we're 20 years we've been
friends our first interactions were
pretty much on the basketball court him
dunking on me or something like that and
then playing fantasy basketball as in
high school together
fantasy basketball that was that was
that where it began I remember I
remember you trade me Rick Smits for
Shawn Marion I remember when your high
school and your wooden your older you
can take advance and it was great I just
got all of his good players yeah
because I could convince him yeah and
it's true it's still it's still a saw
stick yeah it's a grind I mean totally
different game I said to you guys when
you first came in I saw you guys doing a
mock draft and I looked at the calendar
and I was like it is June and you're
getting you're getting visually upset
that Dante Perez it's not lasting until
the 8th round and I'm like that's gotta
be the reason you're finishing top five
top 10 top 20 is there's no offseason a
fantasy football you could just say
three top 20 I would appreciate if we
stopped highlighting their accolades but
but it's when did it go from oh this is
a podcast to we need to do this year
round and it's even if the seasons not
happening we need to keep going I think
that was at inception we were so
obsessed with fantasy we felt like that
was the gap in the market that was what
was missing was people like we launched
our podcast like a week after the Super
Bowl when people were walking away from
their TV sets and we're like no we we
still want to talk to fantasy football
so tightness tea players and we're your
spot that's pretty much what it was so
and we kind of you know figured out what
the show was during those months and
picked up tons of diehards and it was
like it just happened quick and we all
jumped in you know headfirst can you
guys explain to me you're Michael Keaton
obsession deep cut from the show yeah so
there was this there was this Michael
Keaton Jalen Ramsay I I'm not sure where
he ranked him in terms of Batman you
keep going I don't know if you see he's
not number two I'll tell you or not like
he's number one my number one but he's
got to be up there but so we had the
show called the show after the show
where we would just talk about life
anything just is more of like a comedy
show and in that we were talking about
this movie coming out the founder
about McDonald's oh yeah I remember that
and oh it starts Michael Keaton and then
these two guys in sync like it was
rehearsed a hundred times both went I
loved Michael Keaton said that and it
stuck forever so inks now instead of
saying jinx or coke or whatever you say
it's I love Michael Keaton that's
awesome so Josh Norman is the one that
ranked him and Josh Norman
I actually know has an unhealthy
obsession with Batman I actually got to
do a video with him and were in his car
and it was the offseason where the
Panthers just released him and he went
to Washington and I said and the
33-percent knows this I said hey I'm
gonna play the Michael Michael Keaton
theme song the Batman like the new
Batman theme song he said don't do it
I said why he goes that's what I listen
to right before I play and I can't do
that I heard you right now and I'm like
really wow so he's ranked the top
Batman's he went Christian Bale one
that's fine Michael Keaton - can I can
respect that
who do you think he put three it better
be Adam West's he put Adam West's on the
list
oh come on he went value Adam West's
you went val kilmer three okay George
Clooney four and then said Ben Affleck
his last he said he's not even last he's
not on the list trash
yeah we put Clooney with the Affleck
category and then he said Christian Bale
is like Tom Brady like Ben Affleck says
- Nathan Peterman Oh get body yeah which
I don't know who that's insulting more
cuz Ben Affleck was not a great Batman
no no does that make Keaton the Peyton
Manning in this equation yeah I can live
with that are you okay with that I am
comfortable yeah I'm not okay without
him West not being on this list I grew
up I grew up thinking that I could be
Batman because his name was Adam oh he
already had a nearly Adam's grow up to
be Batman
factual information yeah I tried to
convince my league of this and I would
like you guys to explain this to all of
the fantasy football players out there
what is the argument for a kicker 'less
League oh because I know this resonates
with you I tried to sell my league on it
and they went interesting and then like
communications on its leader for years
every year we you know and we get
together we we hold votes right because
we take
this way two series of it and we're so I
petition every year get rid of kickers
and the reason is they have such an
effect on the total outcome yes but you
don't care it all about know how much
kicker research did you do before the
draft because I know you did a ton of
research on all the other positions yes
you spent time you spent money you spent
hours of research and fun you talked
with your buddies you were you were
having planting your flag on this guy's
amazing never once never once did you
think about a kicker but you're gonna
lose that week because of your random
last pick or win that we it's just dumb
get rid of them
I mean the NFL is already trying to like
you know get rid of kickers I feel like
more and more let's let's be the leader
the trendsetter let's set the trend get
around you guys I've been as VP I
haven't been there the whole time but
you're on board I'm strongly on board
you lost to like a twenty two point Matt
Prater game never fair be done remember
when you want to often in the freakin
fantasy playoffs yes yeah you remember
yeah I I think I was in favor of nerfing
them significantly but not eliminating
them because I'm old school what is a
nerf just just cutting the scoring down
so that they don't hurt so bad when they
go random so this is what you guys were
saying - about quarterbacks that they're
running you should get a point every 25
years yeah it's a video game reference
where when they it's a nerve so when
they adjust the player stats down they
have been nerfed yeah this is like the
the new-school side of the table yes and
the old digital rights what about his
briefs boxer briefs engine Tesla I mean
I can keep going yeah yeah whose most
accurate last year some guy who was
number one
in the draft no no no who was number one
in like most accurate do you know who it
is what is there anything
about him that's too traditional besides
everything oh but my fantasy-football
perspective that you think other people
in their league's probably have that
same guy too
I would love to man I anytime that we
you know unfortunately we we generally
agree on most things enough usually
where we disagree is more on a player
you know we we just you know I believe
in Sammy Watkins Andy is very anti see
me walk and stuff like that but when it
comes to just old school takes I think
you covered it with the kicker I am the
quarterback
I think Sammy's is an interesting one
it's guys that you refuse to draft
because either they've hurt you in the
past yep and you still can't get over it
or there's something about them that you
just go I know there's value there I'm
not doing it
Sammy Watkins is your guy you don't you
in the past that's why I'm sure he heard
everybody in the past he's got five
years of hurting people he the fantasy
burns are real though you bring him out
yeah wait especially at the beginning of
the year when somebody that you invested
six months of like research well that's
my guy and then he lets you down mine
I'll never be able to draft Leonard
fournette again no burns because for me
last year
you know Christian McCaffrey was right
there and I thought maybe around the
bend so he's no last but so I went for
net cuz I was like I know he's gonna get
the workhorse that's right but what
burned me about Fernet is it's not just
the fact that he was injured it's that
suspension yeah where it was like that
self-inflicted you're gonna be dumb too
so I have probably forget my other burns
I cannot draft Amari Cooper ever again
yes because and the other wide receiver
that I have is will fuller it's the guys
that I know and DeSean Jackson was in
that lane for a while I'm not gonna
draft someone that half a year I'm going
I don't know what I'm gonna be out there
just I don't want them so those are your
like famous burns that you've had I mean
I'm with the Amari Cooper okay
take of when we did our Chicago live
show he was the guy said what was it
66 percent of the time he like hurts
by the end of the year he's gonna be a
wide receiver one I I don't care because
I can't count on him yes we can
and week out see big burns for me last
year I ended I in our league of record
oh yeah I ended that draft but the best
team you've ever ever seen wait everyone
called it a super team it was awesome
yeah it wasn't LeBron Wade and Bosh
lined up because I had I had David
Johnson Leonard fournette and Devon -
Freeman Wow I mean leaving a draft for
those three last year based on average
trapezes all haha watch out guys but
then david johnson was a disappointment
yep Leonard fournette
advanced Freeman were injured right off
the bat and my team did not win many
games Wow yeah so now could you draft
them next year or like late David
Johnson everyone's kind of saying you
know new offense feeling great year to
recover opt a quarterback that can
distract the defensive ends David
Johnson is fine he's you know he is a
hundred percent draftable I'm good but I
think we're actually working through
something here for me because I I don't
think I realized until this moment how
hurt I was by Devon to Freeman last year
like I don't want to draft them anywhere
I'm very i've been lower and lower than
these you take Devonta Freeman and you
probably passed on someone right you
probably passed on a juju or something
that you're like yeah but this is a
running back is it number one running
yeah I mean I would never pass on juju
how dare you but outside of outside of
that yeah I mean it was just one of
those things where when you're supposed
to win yes on paper on paper and you
lose it's never it so far it has not
been my fault so that's really divide
the Freeman's fault I don't want
anything to do with those knees and
reminded me in our studio our we have
two bathrooms okay one of the bathrooms
has a that's a photo of Greg Olson Wow
because this is all because big huge
like painting you want to talk about
fantasy burns it was the year I mean
this is a couple years back where I mean
Olson was it's like the number one and
at this point
Jason had
the only hole and his team was tied in
so he gave like I'm going for
back-to-back champion straight he traded
the future away look man when you're
trying to keep a dynasty oh yeah so I
trade it for him bolstered my roster and
I knew I knew I was gonna be the
back-to-back champ and right then he
went from being VIII but he was the
number one guy through the first eight
weeks I trade for him and from that
point on he was the tight end 18 like
which is worthless like I would have
been more than useless just keep
grabbing guys off the waiver and playing
him and I did not win the championship
and so he is our bathroom we have two
bathrooms Jeff Fischer and Greg Olson
it's true Fisher which player is the
reason that Jeff Fisher's up because
we're cardinal fence so because Jeff
Fischer yeah Jeff Fischer is now awesome
I was crushing on Twitter right now that
he's just on social he doesn't matter
anymore that was his that was his plan
all along
yeah fly fish in Montana yo you guys
we're doing a show recently and you said
how do we get through the coaching hype
here on the left go show it's called
whoa
big offseason because every year there
are stories where would you believe it
ricky seals jones is gonna tear up your
life so I have a few that I want to know
if there whoa big offseason or whoa big
offseason okay it's all the inflection
first one quote I love it when we can
give running backs the ball in the
passing game
that's one more eligible player that
defense really has to focus on Matt
Lafleur talking about wanting to get
running backs involved in the passing
game in Green Bay whoa or whoa what if I
hit you with a whoa nice a little Joey
blossom action yes this is absolutely a
big time whoa possibility so for you
it's a whoa yes so Eric because Aaron
Jones is a reason why asked us he's
grana see football community I think is
frustrated with two running back usages
the most Aaron Jones and Kenyan Drake
King Andrew no longer has Adam GaSe who
the [ __ ] knows what was going on with
that Aaron Jones though is the reason I
think it's whoa because we even had
Aaron Rodgers a few weeks ago going
why are we not using this guy more yes
so are you guys like getting hyped on
Aaron job salutely gonna shut the [ __ ]
out the most efficient running back in
football last year just couldn't get him
the ball enough still with limited
touches top ten type of performances
five point five a carry I'm all about
Aaron Jones this year because I just
have to believe that Aaron Rodgers will
convince Lafleur or Aaron Jones will
convince Lafleur that he's the best guy
for the job and he's just so versatile
the Green Bay was so messed up last year
whatever whatever had problems were
happening around the front office the
issues were were manifesting on the
field the the fewest carries in Packers
history which is storied was last year
so they have nowhere to go you know it's
great to get him more involved in the
passing game but I think that the the
running passing ratio is gonna be much
more balanced which is good Aaron
Rodgers has always been an efficient guy
you're not a volume guy I think it's I'm
really in on the Packers offense for
where those players are being drafted
right now I think it's gonna be a great
year the the questionable thing is
Lafleur I know it is this it's all
offseason hype where do we go because I
was the third player I would add to that
people were really frustrated was Derek
Henry last year with and that's where
Lafleur came from yeah we don't know
necessarily how much poll he had in
making those calls between Dion Lewis
and Derek Henry but right you saw at the
end of the season this is what can
happen if you just commit it doesn't
matter what's happening this game we're
gonna give Derek Henry the ball right
20-plus times good things really really
happened for Derek Henry and the
Tennessee Titans didn't hear so that
would be what I'm with ain't I think
Andy's the leader of us for Aaron Jones
yes this season yeah but seeing what
they did the shackles of a restraint
they were they were putting on Henry not
giving him the ball Aaron Jones is a DP
right now I think he's a third third or
fourth round guy yeah right I think he's
in that category of people still
concerned about Jamal Williams still
concerned about what is less well your
talk about Derek Henry in that equation
Jamal Williams yes Derek Henry and Aaron
Jones of the Dion Lewis and early in the
year it was
Dion Lewis involved the difference
though is Aaron Rodgers compared to
marcus mariota now now it's like a whole
new game so we're gonna see but that's
why I'm not sure - about the floor we
thought the Titans were gonna be
unbelievable last year I know there was
a lot of hi I got another one for you
this is a repetitive year one this is an
Omar Kelly tweet Devante Parker caught a
touchdown
Devante Parker caught a touchdown
climbing the wall to get a high pass
over the cornerback he stared him down
afterwards whoa I want to say this I
refuse to talk crap about Devante Parker
because in my former life I was a sports
reporter in Louisville Kentucky
Devante Parker went to high school in
Louisville I covered him and I was like
that kids an NFL player went to
Louisville they win the Sugar Bowl on
there to cover it gets trapped and I go
I told you he was an NFL player and in
the last three to four years he if I had
to give a whoa big offseason award
it's a Devante Parker yes because before
the pads come on and all we're doing is
jump balls and run indeed the man's got
it but I come on man tell the truth cuz
watch the practice stare downs he
probably got to save those now right he
owns the offseason every offseason
people want him to be great he it's a
lot like Corey Davis right in the
offseason Corey Davis where's his
pathway to being the number one guy the
draft pedigree in the draft capital I'm
just fatigued I'm far too fatigued I'm
surprised they brought him back but they
did so they got it they gotta do a draft
Avante part know so you would just avoid
it well because the the one thing that
we cannot take away from Devante
Parker's you got it he's an NFL player
yeah the issue that's good when when I
look at taking the the late round swings
and I say who is going late in drafts
that I you know I'm gonna take my shot
on
I don't like pairing it with a
quarterback situation like parkour has I
would rather take Marcos Valdes
scantling and say oh give me Aaron
Rodgers ends up being one of the guys
and I got robbed
the values exactly maybe I'll swing on a
Nikhil Harry cuz if he ends up being
that Josh Gordon for Tom Brady we got
something yeah but when it's Rosen or
Fitzpatrick he with Patrick's actually
it's it's not super force but with a
head coach that's probably like let's
pound the rock and be good on defense
it's got all the makings of a you know
what's the real upside you know I'm
actually oh my god I'm actually in on
Albert Wilson though okay
look underneath quick throw offense
because I'm projecting him to be the
slot wide receiver in I'm you know like
you said O'Shea bringing bringing down a
system that has been very very friendly
very fantasy friendly to the to the slot
position chef Albert Wilson is the guy
who gets that job he's going to see a
lot of targets only they were able to
also bring down Brady who was the number
one fantasy quarterback for like what
was the first four weeks fits but it was
Ryan Fitzpatrick fan cuz you kind of
look like I'm going that's a lot like
and for Halloween we always dress up on
our Halloween show and he went as the
press conference the DeSean Jackson
created press the best part of that
costume was I put a necklace on
sunglasses and then my costume was done
this guy's in full makeup he had he dyed
his hair now is Andy Dalton these guys
are doing shave the beard so that I
could have the Jeff Fisher mustache
dedication you cut your hair a lot you
shaved your head one time yeah I mean
you're really working on this dude right
here would never do that no I'm not
gonna mess up that lettuce got a braid
going I got you I also have good hair
the truth as a man with below average
hair go [ __ ] yourself big offseason this
one's gonna hit you right in the fields
quote I love it when we can excuse me
that's what the same one twice it's
alright alright I'm just gonna tell you
what it is
Kyler murphy Kyler you guys are all are
you all Arizona Cardinals maybe we are
the quote that I saw I actually have it
up right here from Kyler Murray quote
I've always been confident in myself
just trust my abilities trust what I can
do in the football field along with
coach
King Barry's coaching teaching me I
think us together along with the players
that we have that we can be very
dangerous and the reason that I'm kind
of leaning towards whoa is this Cuyler
Cliff relationship the fact that he's
going I know we got it we just got to
get everybody else on board are you whoa
or whoa the relationship between cliff
and Cuyler oh the relationship is strong
it's solid we have to temper our
jubilation fantasy wives for Cuyler
because we're from Arizona so we have to
be careful to Rover it workers if we
like him so you're telling your audience
we're probably a little biased we
probably have them gone a little bit of
higher than he should know we're saying
you're gonna think we're biased because
of how high we have them ranked but
we're right that's what we're saying yes
so that really is the fact of the matter
is is it Mike's brought this up on a
Chicago live show you know high draft
Capital quarterbacks that can run the
football
they always give you top ten seasons
Josh Allen did it last year Lamar
Jackson in the first round last year
needle Mac aways they just do Griffin
the third cuz of what these guys are
scoring is pretty fancy scoring for
quarterbacks is broken in favor of
Russian quarterbacks and so you guys say
let's not bum on the scoring issues
let's take advantage of it
Kyler's the guy did don't hate the
player hate the game but you got so kyla
you guys are excited and not now not as
fantasy football right as actual fans of
the Cardinals no no oh just I don't
think it's gonna be a good year Oh a
real light football but did you like the
whole we're gonna move on from Josh we
think he's a great quarterback but we
think this guy's even better just like
that all takes incredible courage from
the GM to do that one year in like I was
not a rose and fan coming out last
offseason when the draft happened I'm
like oh my gosh now you got three years
committed to this guy
that I don't believe in obviously the
train wreck of a season I think it takes
look it's hard to do when you're a gym
you have to swallow your pride and say
we're just gonna forget last year
existed because they trade it up to get
them a hundred percent a hundred yeah
for rosin yeah you know for me I'm
about Kyler I'm excited about the
opportunity in the offense bringing in
as a Bella and it came Butler yeah I
mean as a Cardinal fan we just give us
the puff piece on Qaeda we sit around
the table I see that video Isabelle
around a forum I did Kyler's going neck
for neck I mean you guys just like
high-fiving each other we start every
morning we just flip that video on it
gets us going yeah Norman plays the
Batman theme we watched carla marie
highlights and that's right yeah it
starts sweating you think I was sweaty
today not yet no no Oh open invite open
come on the show how many of your
fantasy football team names are gonna
have like Tyler in the title or do you
only do that if he's on your team I
think you can only name your team after
a player if that players on your team
otherwise it's really weird what would
be the fantasy football team names named
after a player that you believe should
be in the Hall of Fame
oh I got one like that like it's the one
it's the Demaryius Targaryen yes Wow
like when Demaryius Thomas was actually
so Damaris too and Dan I believe that
putting Zach Ertz with oh my balls Zach
Ertz like that to me is one that I've
seen and I believe it should go into the
Hall of Fame absolutely any other ones
that come to mind if you've got high
burden yeah and and Tyler Eifert
it hurts when I firt yeah that's and
then I mean the one that was in every
single league back a few years ago was
that somewhere over Dewayne Bo great I
mean that was that was everyone little
red for net ooh I also thought oh [ __ ]
hold on you who do you say before a
Fernet because you did threw me off
emotionally right there it's a big
commitment to name your team it is cuz
then what do you do you gonna move that
player you gonna rename your team I did
that last year I had Odell and I like
traded him and I got like Zeke in like
some trade no so would you do it like
Odell Lake did you boy Odell Lake
growing up no I think it was something
with like obj and fernette no I like
that shadow world if there was a it was
a fantasy football hall of fame and it's
for only the greatest performers
in fantasy football hall of fame who
does go into your first class if we had
to narrow it down to five the detail to
inside out yeah I put Peyton in it I
actually do as well he he was
unbelievable for a long stretch and were
anti quarterback in in fantasy but he's
in there okay I'm gonna nominate Adrian
Peterson sure I believe that he had a
long run of being like the number one
pick in the draft yeah he deserves to be
there am I crazy and you guys could say
no priest Holmes
you gotta put Larry Johnson and then if
you hold Shaun Alexander
you gotta put Antonio Brown yes Brown's
four so right now we're at LT Payton
Antonio Brown and did you really want
Adrian Peterson are you just gotta be
nice to know I think Peterson belongs
all right we need a fifth member I don't
know if it's T is it to you you go Gronk
yeah I was wondering time that's what I
was thinking we need to tie it in in
here right yeah you do you do so we
really did a quarterback we got a team
know about Adrian who was the other one
I forgot to run you running back so Y
receiver a quarterback in a tight angle
it's not bad as a good team yeah we're
I'm seeing a lot of people talking about
the disparity and tight end scoring and
how there's always it seems like the
last few years a top three and then
everybody else and I feel like when we
talk about the top three there's also
the notion one of those guys was going
on to perform it's like there's a top
three but really you're you're hoping
you get one of the two in the last few
years it's been Gronk Kurtz and Kelsey
is that fair yep yep where are we right
now at the tight end position right now
it's Kelsey Hertz and Kittel George
Kittel broke out last year you know set
some NFL record yes he's the one that I
think is going to he's like Hertz was
last year right yeah people were not
sure about Earth's going in the last
year
am i right with that I think that's fair
talking to the number one podcast I need
you guys know you're you're absolutely
right nation kelsey hurts both of those
guys like it took a couple years to be
consistent in the position all the hype
is always there oh here comes ooo s--
what's going to happen
kelsey finally delivers Kittel is
interesting because when you break
records when you put up 1,300 plus yards
when you catch 88 passes you're you're
probably not going up yeah you know what
I mean so if you overspend on Kittel I
think that's a mistake I think
belongs in that group I think there are
some interesting names like OJ Howard
yeah the core to have an Engram the
targets in in New York as painful as
they'll be to watch there's gonna be a
lot of them you're going around so I'm a
huge Jack Doyle guy oh yes because for
me there's like tiding committees on a
team that you're really into that well
look I I think you talk about guys are
gonna take a step back sign me up for
Eric eibar take a step back this year
and Jack do to me is just mr. reliable
yeah I'm eight catches he's Daisy five
yards might get a touchdown and at the
tight end look I'm gonna take a roll on
one of the guys you just said yeah or I
might take like wait and go Jack Doyle
huh jack yeah who who are your fantasy
crushes like that don't make any sense
you go back in time my fantasy crushes
Arian Foster that's all my ultimate
fantasy crush of all time as far as this
year man it's Dante Pettis I'm in love
with Dante Pettis this year yeah we both
are I'm in love with Carson wins this
year I've had a fantasy crush that has
been inappropriately strong on Kenyan
drink I think can you drink like is one
of the best running backs in the NFL and
so I always believe I'm I'm a king your
abusive relationship you get within
5,000 feet of Kenyan Drake correct now
legally speaking yes but now the Adam
GaSe is gone I feel like maybe you drank
drinking orange in the Jeep
who's your do you have a crush too I was
reminded of my my passion is love for
jeremyhill eight years ago years ago and
the my my budding that the it's still
the flames they're still being stoked
and every time I try to talk myself into
the the feelings like this this is
accurate I'm always talking myself out
of it but I can't stop in this didi
Westbrook for me this year where I talk
about highlight reel plays and you seem
right let us ISM and you go no more
Blake bortles
exactly yeah Nick Foles is and he's
gonna be the target leader I mean Martin
Marquis leaves should be that guy quote
quote but I mean he's still returning
from a devastating injury as a needle
was that great testicles fan
this is what we were the reason that
Eagles fans started to like big Nick
Nick over Carson Wentz is because Nick
had no feared to just lob it up
yes sir Carson I think sometimes when
you're a quarterback and you have
success earlier in your career you're
looking to just improve all the time and
you don't want to make a lot of the
mistakes but we all know that when your
team's gone for a Super Bowl Tom Brady's
gonna lob it up there to Gronk down
there at the 10 and sometimes you got to
make a play and Nick would just lob it
up to Al Shean or he'd throw it up there
too
so I think about him in Jacksonville
where it's gonna be an offense of like
pounding the rock and then going over
the top
d d like I'm resting don't get me too
excited about TV we're seeing a lot of
stuff like I get sweet easy intelligent
people we kind of um alright so do you
have a sleeper - is there like one
sleeper or do you guys ever not like do
you guys ever stop talking to each other
a certain amount of time before you're a
league of record draft or do you you
have to know who each other like so much
worse because you're like I know you're
looking yes right three of us like we've
we've always talked so much that we
pretty much knew going into drafts even
before we did the pockets but now I hear
they go to any draft in the world
without my personal rankings which are
true like I don't I don't just like a
week before staff just mess up my right
I want to done that year one it was hard
the year one of the podcast was like how
do I do a wonderful podcast and insulate
myself from these legit legit before I
was on board there's an email thread
that we have that we found like a year
ago when Andy and Mike we're starting
the podcast they're talking about okay
what are we gonna name it like what are
how really doing that so much fun at
their biggest worry in that email thread
was people are going to know our picks
and should we should we must continue
started after the draft so that you know
it's like I forgot we that is
unbelievable because this is not even a
fantasy football show and I have my
friends in my league of record at home
that when we're doing the live draft
together they're like and I know left go
what at this pic and I'm
dick stop subscribe yeah they put it
like thanks for listening preciate I
will never be in a league where I get to
draft carry on Johnson because I love
him so much and I talk about fantasy
crush oh there is no bigger fantasy
crush than me with with carrying on
Johnson and if I'm in a league ever you
know the other people in that league
usually know my love and if it's a round
where he might be drafted and they're
right before me it's like it's a win-win
for them they go oh I get to get a
player that I think is good and also I
get to watch Jason scream and cry I'm
taking carry out I love that it's true I
think it's a and I it seems like your
audience right now if something doesn't
go right they don't put the blame on you
guys but I'm sure that's something you
have to deal with all the time I think
we have the built-in advantage of three
of us I mean we don't the thing is as we
go into the show we don't always agree
on every single player right we try to
bring you the information we tell you
don't it's not a template you don't just
draft our rankings I mean you can if you
want right but here's all the
information make your decision and you
know most often we don't all agree on
everything so one of us is right yeah
and we present the information that we
alluded to it that you're the fourth
person at the table we're just we're
discussing fantasy football and we we
want to equip you to be better players
these are our opinions on certain
players but at the end of the day we're
I'm not clicking your lineup in I mean
I'm not putting that waiver Bay p.m.
we're scouting we're trying to help
people out your home league's different
than my home league you know all the
players in that league you know their
tendencies you know who they're gonna
try to steal away from you those are
things that we can't predict for you so
I have a guy in my home League oh that
kolnas I'm trying to find a more
appropriate word he trade blanks people
okay what happens is every year in the
group chat we're going guys
nobody trade with everything just don't
trade with them because he's never gonna
be an even trader you're always gonna be
the one on the short and/or he'll find
the one guy that's not paying attention
and get his best assets how would you
advise how do you handle that sounds
like a great guy
he's not yes that guy in our league and
it was worse because he's the volume 100
he is he just makes so many trades
though into the year like how do you
have Julio and O'Dell yeah it's not just
that it's oh he's so active in throwing
out offers that I think he's throwing
body blows at these people and events in
oh yeah certainly and when Wiig fans guy
man he's surprised sometimes he's like I
just threw this out in it it got
accepted that's what they always say
like apology I have to except Allah Jose
for my trades at the end of them that's
what I like to do to the item you know I
don't know how this happened but what
here I here we are let's make the best
of it and I think you have a better
relation you know in leagues to make
trades you have to have a relationship
with people like you it's so what I
reckon the likes of mind that find the
dumbest people in your league okay build
a relationship with them because that
really Starbucks Jeff's a great guy he's
actually one of the good players they
personnel but Boehm's coming for you
alright so I know that now you guys are
big-time and the odds that you probably
read your iTunes reviews are probably
not that high so what I've done is I've
gathered a 5 star 4 star a 2 star to one
star oh because yes
screw you 3 star guys that's right who
didn't have to be here get it get an
opinion miss hit or miss with this
bucket ok 5 star review from Josh 88
champ champ this show got me to the past
year and all the bragging rights
I'm a fan for life whoo that's the dream
racer and then really because if
somebody wins you a fantasy championship
you're gonna listen to their advice the
rest of your life yeah back in 2015
that's right he nailed that one pick you
got this ring yeah like that's that's
literally the reason I went to Syracuse
is I had I went to college in oh five
and oh three I won my bracket because of
Carmelo Anthony and I was like guess
that's where I'm going to school it's
really 90% the reason that's amazing
goal the other 8% was I love snow a four
star at here's your four star it's
titled unhappy hmm four stars always
interesting gasp it's a always got one
little problem and boy does this guy
yeah this is a Electric Company mmm well
there's a problem your dislike of cats
has lost you a star gentlemen
great work otherwise your chemistry with
each other is wonderful to listen to
worth it we see ya we stand by our our
take on the hats you yeah you take all
the stars you want cats are the worst
how often are you guys talking about cat
apparently one time too many
I mean not much but you've seen if you
bring up cats we're gonna tell you that
they're the worst are you all dog owners
yes I mad are merlinean so what happened
to cats in your foyer well okay cats
seem like they'd be a wonderful pet they
leave me alone
yeah but I'm horribly allergic to them
they want to kill me so I at this point
it's just like plus if a cat scratches
you with your skin tone I don't believe
now I don't think the gym you know it
would look like this battle yes that's
correct
and their spawns of the devil so there's
that Yuri and they're just evil are you
a cat person
no I'm indifferent not any more like a
friendly cat if it like comes up to me
and I got like kittens are I believe the
word you were looking for kittens are
sweet and then they grow up to be cats
all right to star you nervous what
happened to the three I told you I don't
know like if you couldn't pick a side
I'm not gonna read your review I've got
it
two side what do you know em cat 69 less
entertaining more analysis this is going
to get to the heart of creating a
podcast the show would be so much better
if they didn't try to entertain and
would just stick to the analysis yeah we
know what you want this is the crux of
creating a podcast which is everybody
listens for one reason or the other but
really you're trying to make something
that's fun and you're pleased and
everybody but there's one guy that's
gonna be like why didn't you talk about
the Tampa Bay
flex options that's gonna happen mcat 69
or whatever the name was I think they're
probably really into like chalk really
just into you know cleaning products and
spreadsheets which I love spreads if you
want to have something that matters you
got to it has to have a feeling and I'm
you know I'll do it garnish on your meal
when they bring it out by the way I want
you to know that you guys had an
inordinate amount of five stars search
for someone thank you the thing is is we
try to give people we don't release them
we know we know that we're gonna get
that the amount of dad jokes that show
up on our show we're gonna get that but
we want to give you no excuse to listen
which is why we put so much time into
the the analytics and showing up in the
top five because now you've got no
excuse you have to listen top 20 people
we do get a complaint sometimes it work
we're too entertaining the backhanded
compliment rosy right and so when I hear
that when I when I hear people talk
about just your to electric your thank
you you know it's like two days are no
thank you right and I we just have to
deal with that
it's part of her the hardship that we go
through yeah but we accept this so I'm
okay with good feedback know that that's
that would have felt good to read and
this is from arch 23 this is the only
one start I could find and it was fifty
percent chance it refers to my laughing
it's the other fifty percent okay and I
will say what's so interesting that I've
just discovered is he wrote this on
Christmas Eve which I'm like if you're
writing a one-star I do all that from
the heart on Christmas daddy
this man is looking at us holy Santa
donita's cookies what family wait to
hear this that guy's five cats if
getting awful rankings for week 16 is
what you enjoy then this is the podcast
for you they should nominate themselves
for the pooped in their big boy pants
segment after the
suggestions this season is that an
actual segment and yes okay
so this guy is clearly an absolute Foot
Clan diehard and on Christmas Eve
someone picked a player that didn't work
out and he is gonna Harbor that feeling
for the rest I guess I get it I totally
get it because this last year Christmas
weekend was championship week in week 16
so he's saying he made a pic based on
our advice and he lost his championship
because of that and so it's I get the
passion I love the passion I'm okay with
this once actually really good two in
one star like the meanings but I but I
do in a point I just wanna I just want
to point something out you were playing
in week 16 for the championship and odds
are they were using your poopy pants
Rankin you're darn right that's pretty
good
yeah yeah spin zones been zone you
[ __ ] steel with that though what is
the worst piece of a Fanta Fanta see
advice you've ever given out like what's
the one that I'm coming back you could
take it back right now oh I know mark I
will give you a pardon right now all
right lead us off him
there was an off season we're a team had
they they had a fourth round running
back he was the incumbent starter he had
Justin up just a crap I mean as bad as
you can get rookie season they spent a
second-round pick on a running back and
the guy that they picked up in the
second round was Tevin Coleman
the starter was Devon Devon to fringo
yeah and the famous quote of mine when I
would be smirched Freeman frequently is
it was lovely Freeman's Steve Austin
free now as the kinks and that was the
season he went on to be the number one
fantasy running back of the season over
and over and over unapologetically Devon
Springs inks whoopsy doozy and then I
had to issue a full formal pot we put
the sad music cathartic moment yes I was
just a a we a wee bit too bullish on
Tyrod Taylor
just uh just a wee Thursday night ball
jets just a little bit girl the sideline
yeah thank you thank you alright mine
would be last season and on one of our
bold predictions shows yeah I said that
it was the beginning of the end for the
Patriots are you serious I did I look
the right I mean fantasy players for New
England didn't help you see if you drive
wrong if you drive in white they helped
me a lot but yes I will say this the
whole the whole Patriots are going to
end thing is the worst game of double
dutch media people play it's a mistake
everyone is sitting there going you're
not gonna be the one I wasn't even if
you are good to be the one no one's
gonna be like no he saw it coming the
fantasy footballers are the ones that
knocked off the Patriots like no one's
gonna get credit for it so why do we
just keep questioning this time telling
you what okay I was on the outside of
those ropes and I just nailed me
perfectly
I I was saying I'm I'm gonna be the one
I see it clear as day I know I'm and I'm
gonna get credit I am so done there's a
party that's like he knew his eye for
regression is the eye we wanted to speak
it into existence as non patriot fan I
think that's why people do it
they might actually like gotta be the
end now right it was like the Spurs well
I send I said the beginning of the end
gotcha so technically starting at the
top our ends are always beginning what
we're not even to the table of contents
yet in this book yeah yeah I would say
my best piece of advice last year was to
draft Eric Ebron
just because with Frank Reich I was like
double tight end sets that's Andrew Luck
the one that I was very wrong on was Rex
Burkhead I know how I loved birthday I
love them so much it was like you guys
the rotor world community I was like
we're all in agreement here he's the
nerd running back of choice yeah I think
it would have been fine
yeah week one he came out and he got I
think 17 carries I mean he was he was
great yeah fantasy and week one but as
he always does he just and he got hurt
and then he got usurped all right you
guys live show this is gonna be coming
on next week and I apologize but your
show it was on Saturday yeah it was
amazing oh so many moments I mean you
guys crowd surfed all on the show that's
right I mean podcasters are punk rockers
right I'm not even sure I apologize for
crushing be where is the next stop San
Francisco that's correct yeah we're in
San Francisco ballers live.com we'll be
in LA after that and then back in
Phoenix before the season and if people
want to know show dates show times how
to buy tickets they go to where just go
to ballers live.com or you can go to the
fantasy football our second man I'm
excited for all of you congratulations
yes I had a great did you have a good
time hurts
I feel pardon me excuse me I'm addict
you know hitman hitman if you want a
freestyle really quick it's kind of
customary you don't want that know you
don't know how bad I to money fellas you
the [ __ ] aside I come out with my best
bro you 30 33% I appreciate you homey
homey homey
well holla at you later I don't like
cats so I bought a dog
[Music]